président d'une entreprise de
construction
il habite en ontario mais sa société
travaille sur un chantier au michigan
façon correspondre à la définition d'un
travailleur est essentielle
il s'est rendu aux états unis mais à son
retour il s'est vu refuser l'entrée au
canada
ce monsieur legault les agents
frontaliers lui ont dit que sa situation
ne lui permet pas d'être exempté de
présenter un résultat négatif à un test
de kobe 19 ni de s'isoler pendant une
quarantaine de 14 jours lorsqu'il a
refusé de rebrousser chemin
il s'est fait remettre une contravention
de 3800 $
il a eu l'impression que la définition
d'un travailleur essentiel relever de la
discrétion des agents frontaliers
pourtant le président du syndicat qui
représente ses agents affirme qu'il n'en
est rien
depuis la mise en place de la
quarantaine obligatoires
la situation à la frontière serait
devenue chaotique
selon cet avocat elle affirme avoir reçu
au moins une quinzaine d'appels de
travailleurs de différents domaines dans
la même situation
ces citoyens canadiens se sont vu
refuser le statut de travailleur est
essentielle parce qu'ils ne sont pas des
travailleurs transfrontaliers quotidien
à des métiers qui travaille pour
l'orchestré symphonique de détroit mais
habite windsor traverse lui la frontière
chaque jour sans être inquiété il n'y a
pas de sens nous imposer un test en
moins de 72 heures quelque chose puisque
on y va pour quelques heures une
possibilité qu'envisage l'entrepreneur
j'ai donné je pense
même s'il préfère se déplacer uniquement
lorsque sa présence sur le chantier est
absolument nécessaire ici catherine
brulotte radio canada toronto